[Music]
in the German town of nerd Lincoln in
1593 an innkeeper named Maria hala
found herself accused of witchcraft she
was arrested for questioning and denied
the charges she continued to insist she
wasn't a witch through 62 rounds of
torture before her accusers finally
released her Rebecca Lemp accused a few
years earlier in the same town faced a
worse fate she wrote to her husband from
jail worrying that she would confess
under torture even though she was
innocent after giving a false confession
she was burned at the stake in front of
her family
hull and Lemp were both victims of the
witch hunts that occurred in Europe and
the American colonies from the late 15th
century until the early 18th century
these witch hunts were not a unified
initiative by a single authority but
rather a phenomenon that occurred
sporadically and followed a similar
pattern each time the term which has
taken on many meanings but in these
hunts a witch was someone who allegedly
gained magical powers by obeying Satan
rather than God
this definition of witchcraft spread
through churches in Western Europe
starting at the end of the 15th century
it rarely gained traction after the Pope
gave a friar and professor of theology
named Heinrich Kramer permission to
conduct inquisitions in search of
witches in 1485 his first in the town of
Innsbruck didn't gain much traction with
the local authorities who disapproved of
his harsh questioning of respectable
citizens and shut down his trials
undeterred he wrote a book called the
malleus Maleficarum or hammer of witches
the text argued for the existence of
witches and suggested ruthless tactics
for hunting and prosecuting them he
singled out women as easier targets for
the devil's influence though men could
also be witches
Kramer's book spurred others to write
their own books and give sermons on the
dangers of witchcraft according to these
texts witches practice rituals including
kissing the devil's anus and poisoning
or bee witching targets the devil
singled out for harm though there was no
evidence to support any of these claims
belief in witches became widespread a
witch hunt often began with a misfortune
a failed harvest a sick cow or a
stillborn child community members blamed
witchcraft and accused each other of
being witches many of the accused were
people on the fringes of society
elderly the poor or social outcasts but
any member of the community could be
targeted even occasionally children
while religious authorities encourage
witch hunts local secular governments
usually carried out the detainment and
punishment of accused witches those
suspected of witchcraft were questioned
and often tortured and under torture
thousands of innocent people confessed
to witchcraft and implicated others in
turn because these witch hunts occurred
sporadically over centuries and
continents the specifics vary
considerably punishments for convicted
witches range from small fines to
burning at the stake the hunt in which
whole a Lemp were accused dragged on for
nine years while others lasted just
months they could have anywhere from a
few to a few hundred victims the
motivations of the witch hunters
probably varied as well but it seems
likely that many weren't consciously
looking for scapegoats instead they
sincerely believed in witchcraft and
thought they were doing good by rooting
it out in their communities institutions
of power enabled real harm to be done on
the basis of these beliefs but there
were dissenters all along juris scholars
and physicians countered books like
Kramer's hammer of witches with texts
objecting to the cruelty of the hunts
the use of forced confessions and the
lack of evidence of witchcraft from the
late 17th through the mid 18th century
their arguments gained force with the
rise of stronger central governments and
legal norms like due process witch
hunting slowly declined until it
disappeared altogether both the onset
and demise of these atrocities came
gradually out of seemingly ordinary
circumstances the potential for similar
situations in which authority --zz use
their powers to mobilize society against
a false threat still exists today but so
does the capacity of reasoned assent to
combat those
beliefs in the 1950s a modern-day witch
hunt
took place in the United States check
out this lesson on McCarthyism to learn
more about how government officials
aggressively attempted to expose
suspected communists
[Music]